the reaction quotient is symbolized by
the capital letter q and it tells us
whether a reaction is at equilibrium or
not if the reaction is not at
equilibrium it also allows us to predict
which direction the net reaction will go
to reach equilibrium for example let's
look at the hypothetical reaction where
gas a turns into gas b
gas a will be represented by red circles
or red spheres and gas b will be
represented by blue spheres
the equilibrium constant for this
hypothetical reaction is equal to 3 at
25 degrees celsius
let's start by writing out the
expression for the reaction quotient so
we would write out here qc is equal to
and this has the same form as the
equilibrium constant expression so we
would put concentration of b to the
first power divided by the concentration
of a also to the first power
let's look at our first particulate
diagram here and let's think about each
particle representing 0.1 moles of a
substance and the volume of the
container is 1 liter
so let's first find the concentration of
b so we can plug it into our expression
for q
b are the blue spheres so we count up
one two three blue spheres
each sphere or each particle represents
point one moles so three times point one
is point three and then we divide that
by the volume of 1 liter to get a
concentration of 0.3 molar so we can go
ahead and plug in 0.3 molar for the
concentration of b
next we divide that by the concentration
of a and since there are five red
particles and each particle represents
0.1 moles 5 times 0.1 is 0.5 moles of a
divided by a volume of 1 liter gives a
concentration of 0.5 molar for a notice
that we could have just counted the
number of particles three blues and five
reds and just done three divided by five
and get the same value for the reaction
quotient q
so qc is equal to three fifths or 0.6
and kc remember was equal to 3
so q is not equal to k in this case qc
is less than kc
since q is not equal to k at this moment
in time the reaction is not at
equilibrium in order for this reaction
to reach equilibrium q needs to be equal
to k and since q is a lot smaller than k
if you think about it we need to
increase the numerator and decrease the
denominator so that means we have we
have too many reactants and not enough
products and so the net reaction if we
go back up here to to the equation here
the net reaction is going to move to the
right to make more products
so the net reaction moves to the right
to make more blue particles and
therefore the number of red particles
would decrease we can see that comparing
these first two particulate diagrams
here so let's compare the first
particular diagram to the second
particular diagram in the first
particular diagram we had three blues
and five reds and the second particulate
diagram we have five blues
and only three reds so that shows the
reaction has moved to the right to
increase the amount of products and to
decrease the amount of reactants let's
calculate qc at this moment in time for
our second particulate diagram to see if
we've reached equilibrium yet well we
have five
blue particles and only three reds so qc
would be equal to five over three or
five thirds remember that the
equilibrium constant kc is equal to
three
therefore qc is still not equal to kc
and therefore the reaction is not at
equilibrium
and q is actually still less than k
therefore the net reaction is going to
move to the right again to increase the
amount of products and to decrease the
amount of reactants
let's compare our second particulate
diagram to our third particular diagram
in the second particulate diagram we had
five blues and three reds and then the
third one here we have one two three
four five six blues and two reds so
we've increased in the amount of blue
and we've decreased in the amount of red
let's calculate qc for the moment of
time represented by our third
particulate diagram well there are six
blues and only two reds so qc is equal
to six divided by two which is equal to
three
so qc is equal to three and remember k
is also equal to three so qc is equal to
kc and therefore this reaction is now at
equilibrium and at equilibrium the
reactants turn into the products at the
same rate the products turn back into
the reactants and therefore the
concentration of both reactants and
products remain constant at equilibrium
so when q is less than k the reaction is
not at equilibrium there are too many
reactants and not enough products
therefore the net reaction goes to the
right to increase the amount of products
the net reaction continues to go to the
right until q is equal to k and the
reaction has reached equilibrium at that
point the concentrations of reactants
and products stop changing and they
remain constant it's also possible for q
to be greater than k
and if that's true the reaction is not
at equilibrium but in this case you have
too many products and not enough
reactants therefore the net reaction
goes to the left to increase the amount
of reactants and to decrease the amount
of products the net reaction will
continue to go to the left until q is
equal to k and the reaction reaches
equilibrium let's look at another
reaction which is the decomposition of
phosgene to form carbon monoxide and
chlorine gas kc for this reaction is
equal to 2.2 times 10 to the negative
10th at 100 degrees celsius
and let's say we're given concentrations
of phosgene carbon monoxide and chlorine
at a moment in time and asked if the
reaction is at equilibrium or not and if
the reaction is not at equilibrium we
need to predict which direction the net
reaction will go to reach equilibrium
our approach is going to be to calculate
qc at that moment in time and then
compare qc to kc
so first we need to write our qc
expression and this is equal to the
concentration of carbon monoxide raised
to the first power times the
concentration of chlorine
raised to the first power and that's
divided by the concentration of phosgene
so the concentration of cocl2
so at this moment of time the
concentration of carbon monoxide is 3.4
times 10 to the negative 6 molar the
concentration of chlorine is 6.0 times
times ten to the negative six molar and
the concentration of phosgene is equal
to two point zero times ten to the
negative third molar when we plug all
those into our q expression and solve we
get that q c is equal to one point zero
times ten to the negative eight
so in this case qc
is greater than kc because qc is equal
to 1.0 times 10 to the negative eighth
and k and kc is equal to 2.2 times 10 to
the negative 10th and when qc is greater
than kc we have too many products and
not enough reactants therefore the net
reaction is going to go to the left and
there's going to be an increase in the
amount of phosgene
the reaction will continue to go to the
left until q is equal to k and the
reaction reaches equilibrium